it's quite possible Iran will be sucked
in the Americans have sent their some of
their Armed Forces to the area to ward
off the Iranians but should Iran be
sucked in I wouldn't be surprised if the
Iranians are hit by the Americans it's
also quite possible that if the war
degenerates or expands a to involve the
hisbah as well maybe Israel or the
Americans will use the opportunity to
destroy the Iranian nuclear
installations which it is long targeted
in a sense ideologically that is Iran
says it wants to destroy Israel it's
building an atomic weapon with which it
could do this Israel has always said we
will never allow and so of the Americans
we will never allow the Iranians to have
nuclear weapons because they can't be
trusted with them and they intend to
destroy neighbors and so it's quite
possible this might end up with a a
Israeli or Israeli American campaign to
destroy the Iranian nuclear
capabilities